[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
émission spéciale d' espaces au capitole
nous sommes en confinement mais nous
allons tout de même souligner la journée
nationale des peuples autochtones et et
je dois mentionner c'est aussi le mois
national des peuples autochtones nous
sommes en plein dedans et nous pensions
célébrer mais les événements des
dernières semaines vont nous obliger
aujourd'hui célébré mais aussi à
réfléchir parce que vous l'avez vu dans
les nouvelles on a beaucoup parlé de
racisme
il ya eu des événements qui nous oblige
aujourd'hui à nous poser des questions
sur le racisme systémique pour en
discuter
j'ai trois invités avec moi alors je
voulais présente tout de suite
isabelle picard qui est la première
spécialistes aux affaires autochtones de
radio canada isabelle bonjour l'on joue
également à ses côtés ou izia la rivière
ou izia et la co fondatrice d'un
organisme installé à montréal mais qui
rayonne partout au québec et qui
s'appelle mikano nous allons vous
expliquer à leurs ce qu'est n'kana
bonjour médias mangeant et puis nous
avons également eileen gray eisenbrey
est un ancien policier c'est aujourd'hui
un instructeur coordonnateur il s'occupe
de la cohorte autochtone à l'école
nationale de police de nicolet
monsieur bré bonjour bonjour alors nous
allons donc je disais parler de racisme
systémique
le terme en fait il pas nouveau mais il
n'a pas été beaucoup utilisé auparavant
on parlait plutôt on parlait de de
discrimination systémique
et puis depuis 2016 environ le terme
racisme systémique a commencé à sortir
et en fait c'est avec isabelle qu'on va
en parler
isabelle le terme racisme systémique
qu'il est sorti à un moment bien
particulier
tout juste avant que ne commence la
commission vient
oui oui tout à fait
enfin en ce qui concerne les autochtones
c'est un terme qu'on a vu la première
fois dans un rapport de madame fannie
lafontaine qui n'y ait été à l'époque
toujours observatrice indépendante dans
le cadre de la sphère des policiers
devant leur avec les femmes autochtones
qui était en fait que des événements qui
ont été révélée par l'émission enquête
l'odeur radio-canada donc en 2016
novembre 2016 m la fontaine avec edith
farah à la salle et moi même on a tous
signé un rapport qui décrivait le
racisme systémique à l'intérieur ou en
fait qui identifiait ce racisme
systémique là à l'intérieur des forces
policières et donc en lien avec toute
cette affaire de valdes a alors c'est à
ce moment là que le terme vraiment est
ressorti aujourd'hui on en parle
beaucoup plus ouvertement
est ce qu'on pourrait faire tout de
suite pour le bénéfice des spectateurs
des téléspectateurs c'est d'expliquer ce
qu'est le racisme systémique est ce que
parmi vous 3 quelqu'un veut nous
expliquer ce qu'est le racisme
systémique où il ya du temps le micro
mais moi j'ai entendu finalement
plusieurs définitions mais prescrite
dans mes mots c'est vraiment un spasme
qui est présent dans les institutions
savez pendant 120 heures que chaque
individu est raciste mais c'est un
racisme et qui présents dans les
institutions et qui fait en sorte que
les autochtones et les personnes
racistes et vic des discriminations et
les injustices dans plusieurs domaines
que ce soit par exemple à la recherche
d'un emploi dans les chemins
justement quel son sillage la part de
deux policiers dans quoi ma définition
du racisme
oui il est belle est ce que vous aurez
quelque chose à ajouter à cette
définition
en fait oui c'est tout à fait juste
c'est un racisme qui s'inscrit dans le
système dont un grave dans la façon dont
le système est donné finalement aux
citoyens qui voient qu'ils vont traiter
une certaine caste de citoyens de
manière différente donc un certain
groupe de manière différente au niveau
des autochtones c'est sûr que la base de
ce racisme systémique le sait la loi sur
les indiens qui va faire en sorte que
dans notre vie de tous les jours on va
être traité différemment des autres
citoyens donc par exemple on n'aura pas
le droit d'aller ont demandé de l'argent
pour débuter démarrer une entreprise
parce que nos maisons dans les
communautés ne sont pas saisissable donc
ça c'est une discrimination qui est
basée sur la race si uniquement les
autochtones qui vivent dans les
communautés qui sont pas capables de
faire cela donc ce rallye ce système est
clown veut s'inscrire dans des lois dans
les politiques dans les programmes et
c'est ce qui va faire en sorte qu'on va
traiter un groupe vraiment à part oui et
en fait pour les autochtones ce racisme
ne date pas d'hier
donc il date de la création de la loi
sur les indiens et il date du traitement
qu'on leur a fait subir à partir de ce
moment là la recette
oui oui diam il ya les i vous avez comme
l'arrêt à prendre la parole
oui en fait je dire que dans mon
entourage qui sort un tracteur qui
définissent comme aimant le colonialisme
comme une forme de racisme envers des
autres acteurs en fait les relations
système qu envers les autochtones existe
depuis le début fait de la colonisation
des premiers contacts entre les ouvriers
les autres acteurs ni éventuellement
avec la création de la loi sur des
instruments
j'aime dépenser nos destinations qui ont
été servis par des policiers
oui oui je vous ai tous vus réagir
monsieur gris j'aimerais bien vous
entendre là dessus
lorsque vous êtes dans le monde de la
police évidemment et tout ça a évolué
depuis la création de la loi sur les
indiens le monde policier aussi mais
vous en tant que policier ce racisme est
ce que vous l'avez vécu vous même
personnellement est ce que vous l'avez
ressenti est ce que vous l'avez vu être
imposée à adé à des autochtones écoute
merci beaucoup pour les définitions
parce que moi aussi je fais des
recherches exactement ça c'est de juger
la systémique
j'avais des chances ou pas avec des
dracs la police d'un sommet juste à
l'éco nationale je commence ici à 2000
puis écoute quand j'ai entré dans
l'école à 2000 il ya des changements à
sa sagesse que j'ai senti est ce que les
systèmes s'est faite comme les deux
collègues m'a dit tantôt c'est des
protocoles céder quoi laisser des
tortures en place une institution elle
mais quand j'ai rendu ici à 2000 on
était comme deux postes différents
on avait des classes pour jouer avec des
non autochtones ici à l'éco nationale
puis galles ça c'est au début à 2000 est
ce qu'il y ait beaucoup de changements
dans cette période là effectivement
montmort-lucy à l'éco nationale c'est
exactement pour ça pour assurer à les
autres acteurs sont présents dans notre
partie sa connection de police et
joachim unique et toujours avec les
dragueurs de police des 22 corps de
police combien il ya de d'aspirants
policiers autochtones
actuellement l'école nationale de police
mais ça c'est des questions spatiales
causés par des mecs maintenant on avait
un koweït
se pose est terminée les 20 mars à l'éco
nationale mais cause de nos problèmes
avec qu'ovide on est dans processus
maintenant chaque année on avait deux
groupes de pouvoir en anglais puis en
français pense ici à l'éco nationale oui
c'est sensé avec avec la pandémie
actuellement avec tout ce qui se déroule
je pense que la cohorte actuelle a été
déplacée légèrement mais il y aura des
étudiants mais tout ça pour dire est ce
que depuis 2000 il ya de plus en plus de
jeunes autochtones qui ont en vue
d'ancrer dans la police et qui se
présente et qui s'inscrivent à l'école
nationale de police
mais écoute 21 ici à l'éco nationale je
vois beaucoup beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui sur certains c'est c'est pas
facile
garder des personnels on avait beaucoup
de corps de police municipaux sûreté du
québec dans france-québec engagé les
autochtones garde également notre groupe
les noms de personnes dans notre corps
cam a réussi beaucoup parce que notre
formation c'est effectivement le jeu
seulement pour les autochtones avec un
premier embauche puis on est comme dans
période sérieux et on fait des
recrutements partout tout est organiste
et qu'android sont en processus pour
recruter mais c'est pas facile ça c'est
sûr c'est évident pourquoi c'est
accessible mais écoute les options
aujourd'hui nos jeunes dans les périodes
quand je commence dans pauliste 92 n'y a
pas grand choix car pour une jeune
personne ne cherche un job full time et
avec un indice à la toujours
mais aujourd'hui avec toute l'éducation
les possibilités pour nos jeunes c'est
incroyable aussi fait des paulistes dans
votre humilité c'est pas facile non plus
avec des connaissances à tout le monde
et nous ont fait des crises et obtenu
des baisses police est déjà commencée
avec leur personne mais ici on avait un
petit problème aujourd'hui pour recruter
police maintenant il travaille les
passants travail pour lesquelles
reposent ces une attaque tant pis ça
c'est un problème déjà adressé par la
police oui mais il ya une chose qui
m'intéresse vous avez dit que les jeunes
autochtones dont qui entre à l'école
nationale de police ont un emploi après
dans le neuf comme messi à de jeunes
autochtones qui veut devenir policier
qui ne veulent pas travailler noté mais
dans la société en général
oui effectivement parce que ça c'est
nous on donne des formations ici à
l'école pas réparer comme des non
autochtones il ya 548 étudiant à l'école
dans la cape town vient chaque année
nous on avait deux trois et les diplômes
quand les deux groupes sont terminés
d'un attaquant qui attaque séparée notre
diplôme c'est bon pour toute l'école de
police surtout du québec
sm partout puis mais ça prendra mais
sans bojic immédiat cartonne pour entrer
dans notre programme à nous parce que
donner des formations pour les arcanes
en anglais ni français sur wii mais mais
ce que je veux savoir c'est un jeune
autochtone il a une promesse d'
embrouille absolument dans sa communauté
qui pourrait décider de venir travailler
à montréal à l'est du caire chicoutimi
[Musique]
ça arrive souvent jeunes hâter sa fin
les deux derniers années beaucoup l'ont
jeunes décèdent affectivement pour aller
dans notre service award
quand la police autochtone c'est triste
mais ça arrive c'est un choix de ces
personnes là c'est triste pour les
conseils de bande c'est rispoli services
de police parce que les investissements
l'argent dans cette personne c'est
énorme
oui non je comprends mais ce que vous
pensez que c'est triste isabelle et vous
dit est ce que c'est pas au contraire
très bon call un jeune autochtone est en
vie lui aussi de travailler en dehors de
sa communauté par exemple et d'aller
d'aller dans une ville ou dans une autre
région
mais ce qu'on sait en cause que
j'entends beaucoup de la part de
policiers c'est que ce n'est pas
toujours facile comme le secret le
disait de travailler dans sa propre
communauté parce que souvent on a
affaire à sa famille on a affaire à des
amis on se connaît tous sa les
communautés sont très petites
maintenant je comprends aussi que
l'investissement vers le futur policier
est important de la part de la
communauté
mais il ya quand même un côté
intéressant cela du fait qu'un
autochtone wassermann y travailler par
exemple à badaroux ou à la tuque ou à
chicoutimi en ce sens que il veut être
donc un autochtone et qui va pouvoir à
quelque part resplendir c'est peut-être
pas le bon mot mais il faut pouvoir
influencer ou entre eux essayé
d'expliquer certaines choses du fait
qu'ils les autochtones
un des moyens de contrer le racisme et
s'est prouvé c'est d'avoir donc
d'embaucher l'immunité à l'intérieur des
organisations peu importe qu'elle soit
policière qu'elle soit ou non
gouvernementales la fonction publique et
cetera et ça ça va permettre de teintes
et un peu c'est le mot que je cherchais
donc de tenter davantage les actions qui
confère au contact de cette personne ne
donc ce n'est pas non plus à négliger
c'est un par le alors c'est dans les
services publics qu'on parle beaucoup de
racisme systémique que ce soit la santé
la justice l'éducation le monde policier
également oui dia quand vous travaillez
parce que votre organisme d'ailleurs on
va l'expliquer tout de suite ni cana il
est là justement pour papa faire de
l'enseignement en mai pour ouvrir les
esprits c'est bien
2 dani sont garnis de faire de
l'éducation et de la sensibilisation au
québec et au canada qui on se prend des
différentes manières avec que ce soit
par exemple une animation d'ateliers
formation le développement d'outils
par exemple on a fait un livre qui
démystifie 10 des préjugés comme mon
comme si des partenariats de grande
envergure donc à ce que ce pari il
formation de quelque chose de ponctuel
une fois qu'il savait des grèves mais
qui peut pas nécessairement 45 il va y
avoir des changements significatifs
mieux donc on crée aussi des
partenariats
justement avec des milieux qui va tout
faire pour mettre en oeuvre des
changements significatifs dans leur
milieu
en termes d'inclusion du pape aux
personnes de respect oui donnez nous un
exemple par exemple aller qui allez-vous
travailler récemment mais je voudrais
qu'il ya un gros partenariat avec le
collège ahuntsic donc un projet qui
nourrit de 3,20 et le codage cet
investissement dans une démarche
d'optimisation de décolonisation de son
milieu vraiment à différents niveaux
c'est pas mal qui ont justement de la
formation du personnel du collège comme
oran le collège à vue culturellement
sécurisant pour les étudiants et tous
ceux ci avaient été déclarés par leurs
réflexions
un lien avec le nom de la rue petit
sportif qui était en scène
anciennement les indiens on savait les
méthodes et des bottes en remise en
question ou non de ce sont les encore
battu ce qui se passe maintenant changer
le prénom de reckitt sportive et
s'appelle maintenant les impôts mais
bref tout ça pour dire que que ce
partenariat avec le collège ahuntsic
ce faisceau nous aurait trois ans qui
emmène ce faire un changement d échelle
sur wii donc ce sont eux qui sait le
collège qui vous a approché pour venir
faire la conscientisation chez eux
oui oui c'est le calage qui justement en
inquiétant réflexion bien que le nom de
leur équipe sportive c'est eux qui nous
ont lâchés pour faire notamment pour
animer une conférence et un atelier
partie leurs personnages ça lui allait
amorcer une réflexion qui normal désir
de travailler davantage
oui mais est-ce que vous voyez une
ouverture aussi de la part de d'autres
organismes institutions qui viennent de
plus en plus vers vous je pense que les
derniers événements dans les dernières
années ont remis des questions à l'ordre
du jour quel que soit donc c'est
l'impression que ma effectivement les
200 passes du bidule qui deviennent
conscientiser qui désirent faire des
changements
mieux en termes d'inclusion une époque
docteur mais je dirais que ça varie
encore parce que nous on travaille avec
des gens justin qui ont une certaine
ouverture et accepte certains désirent
dès le départ de peut-être donc mais
dieu qu'il s'en fout pas encore pris un
set non vraiment avec ni les gens qui
tels des parieurs c'est soyons une
ouverture
en espérant qu'ils deviennent justement
des efforts de bonne pratique
entièrement inspiré tant mieux oui oui
absolument
isabelle vous avez eu l'occasion
j'imagine de de travailler avec divers
organismes qui vous ont permis de voir
comment au sein de ces organismes là ou
d'organismes autour
comment l'évolution se faisait aussi ce
que vous l'avez vu au cours de votre
carrière cette ouverture vers le monde
autochtone et l'envi de les intégrer
dans leur monde
il y eu effectivement depuis un bon
moment je dirais quand même mieux une
belle ouverture au québec en particulier
un faut dire qu'on avait quand même du
chemin à faire au québec marc rapport à
certains autres provinces notamment la
colombie britannique qui est venu en
avance sur nous mais quand même depuis
un an dont nomura
depuis en fait des pensionnats donc à
partir du moment où un monsieur à peu
relevé le voir son pensionnat les
québécois se sont mis à comprendre
certaines choses certaines réalités
liées aux autochtones que vont il y
avait peut-être certains comportements
sur des enjeux qui est éric était
historique et on ne connaissait pas
finalement la base de tout ça et quand
on a levé le voile sur les concerne
l'enseignement c'est peut-être pas de
leur faute ensuite il ya eu des moments
bien sûr à deux longueurs qui a commencé
bon c'est dans l'ouest canadien mais ça
a été un événement planétaire le yoyo
lui partout des protestations des
manifestations des événements montrent
en europe aux états-unis qu'au canada
donc ça quand même et hélas étant
également est là depuis ce temps là on a
vu des québécois des canadiens qui sont
venus nous appuyer qui sont devenus des
alliés ont le vue donc des citoyens
monsieur madame tout le monde mais on a
vu aussi une ouverture ou entretenant le
désir de changement à l'intérieur des
organisations je dirais qu'il ya
plusieurs vitesses en tous sens un peu
comme vous dire le disais il ya des
endroits où c'était peut-être plus
facile on veut faire des changements des
actions rapides
il ya d'autres endroits où les bateaux
les paquebots sont vraiment un grand
vraiment gros vraiment lourd nommément
le gouvernement donc c'est vraiment plus
difficile de faire les changements entre
dont monsieur trudeau va en faire
beaucoup et on parle beaucoup depuis le
début de son premier mandat déjà ils
n'ont pas encore atteint estime
notamment pour l'eau potable
donc c'est vraiment pas facile à faire
peut-être que c'est le système justement
qui est à questionner là aussi mais ce
que je peux dire c'est qu'effectivement
il y aura une ouverture est ce que la
compréhension réelle de ski et la
discrimination ou de ski et l'inclusion
et là je pense qu'on n'y est pas encore
on est en train de de se questionner de
réfléchir avec tous ces débats qu'on a
dans l'est dans les dernières semaines
notamment mais aussi avec tous les
rapports qui ont été déposés je pense à
la commission vient qui parlait de
discrimination systémique le rapport de
madame la fontaine raciste estime et les
fadas mais elle doit aussi en grand sur
le colonialisme liés au racisme
systémique et à la discrimination un peu
comme les médias donc on est en train de
réfléchir à tout cela ce sont des mondes
quand on parle de racisme systémique
qu'ils peuvent en faire reculer quelques
heures moi je pense qu'au contraire il
faut essayer de le comprendre puis de
discuter pour vraiment trouver des
solutions le plus concret plus à une
réelle inclusion des autochtones en plus
partout dans la société
oui alors je suis des récents de huy
allez-y vous dire allez-y c'est ma femme
et moi se trouve en fait un des grands
défis que j'ai réalisé que c'est pas
nécessairement relier à avoir des bonnes
vacances
comment on a réalisé justement de
travail et comment réaliser ce que les
gens les personnes avec toi des bizuths
autochtones font sans assad et inconfort
face aux caisses conducteur aura six
mecs qui vêtu avec papa d'octobre et des
exemples de ces un corner
c'est sûrement par exemple la forme de
faire des erreurs
un sentiment d'impuissance la petite
bille d'agacement des questions pétain
missive ans et un confort de même
justement une action de sensibilisation
ou tout ennemi on a vu ce qui était dit
face à la question c'est quand même
c'est une canne c'est quand même un défi
d'essayer de faire un saut que vous
acceptez ou les gens avec qui on
travaille
puisque justement surmonter c'est un
comique qui amène éventuellement avant
d'éventuellement des blocages qui
finalement en train de cette secousse
donc c'est pour ce 5e 2 comme les des
personnes durant les études puis ensuite
on réussit avec les condamnations fait
quand même un processus qui quand même
complète
oui on parlait des différentes
commissions il ya eu plusieurs
commissions sur les peuples autochtones
au cours au fil du temps cette semaine
le 15 juin le premier ministre legault a
parlé de la création d'un comité
d'action parce que une commission et à
comité d'action je sais pas s'il y aura
une différence on va le voir mais quand
on part du comité d'action donné
l'impression qu'on va se mettre en
marche et qu'on va faire bouger les
choses
est ce que ça pourrait éveiller les
consciences si ça fonctionne il ya
beaucoup de travail là on leur a dit ok
comité d'action ils sont sept huit
personnes ils ont les télés l'automne à
l'open doivent rendre leur rapport avec
des actions concrètes qui seront mises
en place est ce que le fait que ça
vienne du gouvernement ça peut éveiller
la société isabelle je vous vois tous
réfléchir
oui oui c'est une grande question en
fait je n'ai pas vu le nom des
commissaires je sais pas comment ils
vont les appeler mais et des gens qui
vont travailler à ce comité leur jeu
c'est parce qu'il ya au moins un
autochtone d'un clic et pour moi avec
soit 90 québec avec comme si on vient ça
serait un minimum
est ce qu'un homme non il y en a pas c
est malade
oui il ya le député d'ungava denis
lamotte qui travaillent dans les
communautés mais il ya madame sylvie
d'amour de ministre des affaires
autochtones et mais ya pas de tonnes oui
alors je suis pas surprise moi je pense
que si on veut faire des changements il
faut commencer par faire des changements
à l'intérieur de ces comités là qui sont
souvent dirigées par des gens qui sont
impliqués en politique bien sûr j'ai vu
que monsieur qu'armand allait y être
notamment bien sûr il fait partie d'une
minorité dont kilovolts pour apporter à
voir cet apport l'homme et il se trouve
ça extrêmement mavs qu'il n'y a pas de
docteur à l'intérieur de ce comité leur
a d'autant plus avec la commission vient
est d'autant plus que monsieur legault
s'est même excusé il a dit que le québec
a failli à son devoir à l'égard des
autochtones pendant des années des
décennies
si on veut faire des changements que
vous vous impliquez on peut pas faire
des changements sans nous
puis c'est pas une ou deux réunions de
l'assemblée avec l'assemblée des
premières nations qui vont régler
quelque chose ils ont essayé ça dans la
dernière année a été un fiasco
donc pour moi il faut nous inclure à
l'intérieur de ces changements de ces là
bas oui oui parce qu'en fait c'est un
comité évidemment qui s'adresse qui va
toucher les minorités pas seulement des
autochtones et les minorités mais bon
voilà
mhidia ce que vous vouliez ajouter
quelque chose à propos de ce comité
d'action contre le racisme et qui n'est
pas sûr qu'il y avait un monsieur
colonna n'a pas parlé de racisme
systémique mais bien de racisme en même
temps ce que le christ a bien offert
toute initiative qui fait justement à
lutter contre
la situation doit nécessairement les
personnes déjà présentes et groupes qui
sont directement concernés sur l'a6 mais
cette discrimination
puis j'ose espérer mieux de tonnes sa
filiale aider à débloquer les amériques
au convoi des commissions avec
recommandations en fait donc quand même
envie fils d'action avec dès maintenant
j'ose espérer au moins cinq filles
habitent deux des rapports de ces
différences oui monsieur bré la
commission vient à déposer son rapport
il ya neuf mois
il ya beaucoup de ces recommandations
qui touchent le monde de la police
justement est-ce que déjà à l'école
nationale il ya des des actions qui sont
entreprises pour essayer d'aller former
les jeunes policiers qui ne sont pas
encore sur le terrain mais qui vont y
aller donc les préparer un nom pas
affronter non pas confrontés mais être
ouvert par exemple des policiers notent
atone qui vont se retrouver dans des
communautés autochtones ou qui vont se
retrouver en milieu urbain où je vais
donner un exemple soir caveau à montréal
parce qu'un beaucoup d'autochtones qui
vivent dans ce quartier là est ce que on
les prie pas à cette réalité là et est
ce que certaines des recommandations
peuvent s'appliquer déjà dans la
formation et des aspirants policiers et
coach j'ai écouté madame picarde par des
pour l'émission vient puis toutes les
recommandations puis présentement l'écho
nationale puis jeu complètement d'accord
c'est important ccc un importance
important est important de rester
toujours toujours sur un qui me dit si
legault commencé comme tu dis tantôt qui
métier pour ou enquêter toutes sortes
est à présent temps en temps une
présence et
c'est important - ici à l'école
nationale
j'ai sur un cumul type récemment avec
l'école pour assurer causer des
recommandations de l'émission vient ou
intello formation sur la table
présentement vous formez des autres
acteurs jeu pas pour les autochtones
non mais pour les autochtones pour les
futurs des enquêteurs aux agressions
sexuelles puis il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de facteurs maintenant puis j'ai
apprécié sur mon présence dans cette
limite est de procès c'est crucial c'est
important pour nous miller park town on
fait des avances à l'école beaucoup ses
succès pour son nom présence à l'école c
et 10 c
c'est important pour assurer des voix
des autochtones sont toujours écouté par
tout le monde
j'espère c'est garde jessold autochtone
récemment à l'école nationale de police
mais ce qu'on va continuer comme ça
j'aime les chansons engagées de renom de
l'autochtone aussi de inuh de personnes
et une policiers de l'ordinaire kanaky
mais ça c'est mon rôle à l'école ou
assuré nous on a bien une voie dans tout
ça puis c'est tellement important
oui mais là je vous entends parler
vous travaillez à l'école nationale de
turtle de police vous travaillez vous
êtes un autochtone qui travaillait avec
les autochtones
mais est ce que votre voix est entendue
chez les non autochtones chez les
aspirants policiers qui veulent devenir
autochtone pour qu'ils comprennent la
réalité qu'est ce qu'on leur donne comme
formation directement à l'école à la
base et 4 c'est une bonne question parce
que la garde
pour quatre ans nos autochtone cd
ressemble de mal
un matin avec 216 non à cape town toutes
les autochtones ici à l'école porter son
uniforme son parti son service de police
ou encore la police nous beaucoup des
corps de police et des blue black
uniforme ce sont les couleurs tu vois
maintenant écran c'est un coureur de
l'équipe nationale nos jeunes
autochtones porté l'uniforme des sharks
à la police comme lac simon ou du wan et
tout ça mais il intègre et ses laitages
pour nos jeunes pour expliquer beaucoup
choses je trouve c'est incroyable les
façons le matin les interactions
maintenant avec 216 étudiants plus notre
acteur en anglais et en français pour
expliquer cd comme des coachs trouve
jeunes pour les aider
pour expliquer ces quads et réalité dans
certains corps de police c'est quoi des
réalités mais c'est quoi les des
problèmes financement pour vous cherchez
des formations des finances mais tout
cela mais on n'avait rien dit
complètement différent comparé isabelle
vous êtes la première spécialistes
concernant les enjeux autochtones à
radio canada c'est un poste qui est
nouveau j'entends ce qui se passe à
l'école nationale de police de nicolet
un autochtone pour l'instant peut-être
un peu plus ardu cadre est ce qu'on fait
mieux
radio-canada au niveau 2 des employés
autochtone pour l'instant il y à une
journaliste autochtone il y à une autre
journaliste qui est étudiant tant
qu'elle est là à temps partiel et il y
un mois à ce que je sache il peut y en
avoir d'autres
au niveau des cameramans ou autre mais à
ce qu'on m'a dit pour l'instant ça
serait ça au niveau des effectifs
donc c'est sûr que tout à l'heure je
parlais de l'importance d'avoir des
unités à l'intérieur des
de la fonction publique ou de
différentes organisations radio canada
évidemment fait partie de ce lot là il
va falloir chez radio canada augmenté et
on le sait c'est une de mes priorités à
une des priorités qui ont été disons un
mot décrié ou pour des crimes et a prêté
par autant la présidente madame
catherine tate que la vice présidente au
niveau de radio courait du
vice-président où il voudrait d'eau
canadair que mes propres parents ont
donc ça c'est une des priorités
l'embauchent d'autochtones à tous les
niveaux justement à radio-canada pour
justement être capable de venir un peu
teinté et mieux refléter finalement le
canada d'aujourd'hui parce que c'est ça
la mission de radio canada
c'est vraiment de refléter toute la
diversité qui s'inscrit à l'intérieur du
canada et du côté francophone donc si
c'est une autre histoire mais du côté de
radio-canada a des efforts à faire au
niveau de l'arbre qui vont venir tenter
justement vend des chaussures plus de
journalistes autochtone 20 savoir
probable probablement venir teinte et la
quantité d'histoires ou d'actualités
autochtone bien que radio-canada il faut
pour fou de se dire on fait un énorme
travail dans les dernières années depuis
notamment espace autochtone depuis trois
quatre ans on voit beaucoup d'histoires
qui se rapporte aux autochtones
mais maintenant de les raconter avec nos
propres voix ça peut être aussi très
intéressant le pour autant à l'intérieur
de radio canada qu'à l'externe pour les
gens à la maison qui vont recevoir ses
ouïes est donc vous la voyez l'ouverture
à l'intérieur de cette grande boîte là
est ce que oui dia est ce que
l'ouverture vous la santé de plus en
plus vous avec avec mick hannah quand
vous vous déplacez
est ce que vous allez à la maison
d'ailleurs des gens des fois pour leur
dire vous avez besoin de nos services
on n'en est pas encore là parce que
et vraiment étonné intelligent
organisation mais je devrai mieux on
doit refuser certaines demandes parce
qu'on dirait que justement il ya une
prise de conscience tout en même temps
tellement jeune il veut faire des
changements dans leur milieu mènera qui
est rapidement et le maire se souvient
du canada demandent une personne c'est
comme dans toute la thaïlande
rapidement dès maintenant c'est aussi
l'assemblée aussi qu'il faut expliquer
aux gens qu'il a emmené des champions
c'est pas une check-list fait jour dans
un processus peut prendre du temps puis
des efforts faits jusqu'à ce que mon
premier en 106 ans et quand je vois dans
certains milieux qui justement ont déjà
fait avoir une espèce de fait cette
université pour régler dans leur milieu
la crise if mais comme je disais plus
tôt où je veux quand même de plus en
plus de l'ouverture quelques années je
commençais impliqué puis comme disait
mairie milieu qui ont des super bonnes
intentions aussi vous doivent pas être
hostile c'est parce que quand de racisme
et de discrimination par le serment de
juin confirmant qu'ils ont concernant
des comportements et on a su constamment
raciste
affirmer comme variable par des gens
dorment en décoiffer tout âge et des
comportements
la plupart des gens ont répondu oui non
mais je ne sais pas si vous avez par
exemple entendu la question par exemple
des billets inconscient donc par exemple
que mon nez des préjugés des gens qui
peuvent avoir des préjugés envers des
personnes contactent sommes par exemple
et qui fait que ce que j'ai vu ce moment
où il tentait dans leur comportement de
manière inconsidérée des étudiants qui
sont mieux prouver notamment dans l'ue
la sortie ou est-ce que des personnes
docteur qui se vendent qui aurait pu la
destination d'un port de personnes de la
santé que c'est ces personnes une à
chanter les gouvernements persistent
mais qui avait quand même eu des
comportements humains pouvant par des
personnes autres acteurs justement qu'en
voyant personne qui est un écrit ces
lignes qui est honnêtement penser qu'ils
étaient montés des guillotines parce que
à cause de plus juste des autochtones et
l'alcoolisme
donc c'est ce qu'il faudrait c'est un
peu plus complexe que de dire que des
gens qui ne sont pas sans se désole jean
à aix en ergny dirais qu'il ya quand
même comme une espèce d'échelle sur dix
est où
mais bien sûr se situe sur une échéance
au 18 nouvelles ce sont des parements le
deux roues est ce que les gens et sa
troupe pour les chaînes on s'ajuste
donc c'est ça mais pour répondre à la
question son père sur wii en chantier
quand même de plus en plus d'ouverture
mais il ya quand même encore se pressent
et 206 et d'être accompagné
oui il avait juste ajouter le il y eu
donc il y aussi une ouverture mais
comme disait oui dias c'est un
dégrèvement variable là où c'est plus
difficile c'est d'avoir une réelle prise
de conscience et cette prise de
conscience n'a elle est absolument
essentiel je pense
pour as élite 2 d'enrayer finale par
cette discrimination liée aux
autochtones ou ce racisme e lle aux
autochtones qui provient en grande
partie de la manière dont le système est
construit maintenant ce système là il
est il est composé d'individus sains et
donc c'est donc un peu au bon vouloir de
chaque individu de s'informer de ces du
pied de discuter et de vraiment réalisé
ce que c'est d'être de l'autre côté de
la clôture m
les autres avec un grand à 1 mais jusque
d'être un peu à part et cette prise de
conscience là pour moi elle est
essentielle à une véritable inclusion
parce que le contraire du racisme c'est
ça pour moi c'est l'inclusion une ville
inclusion qui est base où était donc il
faut tenir compte des réalités des
minorités notre côté les autochtones par
exemple pour de leur embauche un disons
pour ce qui est des journalistes bien
normal ont montré un baccalauréat en
journalisme
on sait que chez les autochtones y croit
3% de la population qu'un baccalauréat
up si on cherche en plus en journalisme
y en a pas dans les écoles autant à
l'uqam et l'université laval c'est très
très rare
donc il faut trouver des moyens pour que
ces gens-là plus savoir où le voir à
l'intérieur des institutions comme
radio-canada donc qu'ils vont faire en
sorte qu'ils vont être entendus mais
basée sur une réelle inclusion c'est à
dire sur la leur et l état ou leur
réelle réalité finalement je pense que
pour moi ça c'est vraiment un point
avant qu'on va être rendu à faire seuils
de reconnaître certaines choses qui est
pas seulement une manière d'être et une
manière de d'arriver quelque part dans
la vie au niveau professionnel web et là
on va réellement avoir une véritable
fusion mais c'est pas ça c'est pas
facile c'est un très grand défi qui va
se faire sur plusieurs années mais il
faut qu'on ait ces disques
justement pour pouvoir un jour y arriver
à cette éthologue de reconnaissance de
l'autre dans ce qu'il est dans sa
réalité à lui et est ce que vous pensez
que dans toutes les organisations de la
société on est prêt donc quand je prends
des organisations je parle enfin de tous
les services publics que ce soit la
santé la justice l'éducation là on
parlait du monde des médias
mais ailleurs dans la société est ce
qu'on est prêt à ouvrir ses oeillères
finalement et puis à comprendre l'autre
personnellement je trouve qu'il n'ya pas
encore eu cette prise de conscience
assez forte
on est en train de définir un certain
terme leurs astuces insisté mais quand
tu commences à l'accepter tranquillement
c'est pas quelque chose qui se fait jour
au lendemain c'est normal quand elle a
été placée en situation d'exclusion
c'est tout à fait normal de ne pas tout
à fait bien comprendre quels peuvent
être au quotidien les micros agressions
dont peut être victime comme autochtones
communauté donc c'est tout à fait normal
de commencer à s'ouvrir et puis à
apprendre
l'important c'est vraiment de continuer
dans cette voie leurs ailes saunier
encore que tout à fait millio début
discussion puis ça c'est la base donc
moi je suis extrêmement encouragés quand
même par la suite des choses il va il
faut pas qu'on commence à dire justement
comme on entend parfois bon encore le
racisme encore la race et systémique
encore les jeunes est-il encore on nous
accuse c'est pas c'est pas l'idée ce
n'est pas d'accuser personne l'idée
c'est d'avoir une conversation voir
ouvrir les esprits pour pouvoir arrêter
et mieux se comprendre pour mieux
avancer ensemble comme ceci oui aux
médias ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
avec isabelle de le chemin est encore
assez long à affranchir mais on est sur
la voie
oui il va en fait partie effectivement
quelques échanges ils étaient amorcées
au niveau des années mais qui a encore
énormément travaillé à bail à faire puis
c'est vrai que batum des approches que
parmi en termes de raciste j'ai entendu
des gens dire que tant qu'on vendrait ce
n'est pas nécessairement on ne devrait
pas parler de personnes négatives
c'est comme que que le mot craint ce
triste soit 1,4 caractéristiques de
l'analyse l'étude mais plus les
caractéristiques dans le comportement
qui n'est pas vraiment plus défavorisés
en fait le mot raciste parce qu'il est
tellement comme connotation à ce double
qui fait que kelly gens souvent et c'est
d'éviter justement d'en parler ça crée d
un camping de ruisseaux comme avant moi
même je sens que de soins des filles
comme personnes assistaient ce que j'ai
déjà eu des comportements grâce à son
climat toi je pensais comme parce que de
se trouver des pistes de réflexion chez
jean coutu peut savoir cette semaine à
une prospection le raisonnement qui ont
le sentiment qu'ils sont attaqués en
tant que personne blanche alors que
personnes en cocktail que justement
comme à venizel nous sans lui ça comme
une réflexion combien mal comment les
personnes membres c'est justement
devenir des amis ou youtube consommation
monsieur grille pour terminer je vais
terminer avec vous avez vous
l'impression qu'à l'école nationale de
police
le il ya des ailiers pour pour préparer
ces jeunes autochtones à affronter la
réalité policière et inversement pour
les jeunes non autochtone qui vont
peut-être se retrouver dans des
communautés autochtones à travailler ben
écoute
j'ai écouté les deux personnes encore
merci aux votes bon commentaire d'un
sommet moi je parle milieu police écoute
[Musique]
nous à l'éco national on fait notre
effort pour assurer les formations à
l'école nationale il va rester avec
notre présence comme je dis quand on
avait découvert dans bartis on y tourne
mon jeu court donner des formations j'ai
engagé des rougeurs des personnes pour
former nos jeunes nos jeunes sont formés
dans un aspect de connaissances cause de
nous notre présence mais aussi la même
temps il ya un connaissance parce que
j'en ai beaucoup d'épreuves aussi céder
non autochtone puis cet étudiant la c1
plus plus parce qu'il ya des deux
réalités formation à la base si c'est
prpg non la cape town et 216 étudiants
il ya des programmes et des situations
des scénarios où l'on appliqué avec une
réalité peut-être potentiels facteurs
mais nous comme juger notre présidence
allait casser c'est important pour toi
parce que c'est des jeunes gens aux la
cafétéria d'un rassemblement est posé
question c'est dit et du qatar ou non
nos territoires cocktail dit oui dans la
conversation aurait coupé alors je vous
ai perdu pendant quelques instants les
voyez il ya un gros souci dans mon jeu
vidéo
alors oui vous pouvez terminer ce que
vous disiez oui bon c'est juste garder
l'association des directeurs de police
au québec présentement on avait un
représentant dans ses tableaux je trouve
ça ça s'est tellement tellement
important on avait un voix avec d'autres
acteurs de police souffrance québec
c'est des choses comme ça c'est
important pour nous on est dans bharti
ce une réalité différence spéciale à
demande un besoin différent aussi
mais c'est toujours une question de
l'argent ça coûte l'argent pour vous
former des personnes pour les enquêteurs
est tout sommet écoute on est toujours
dans la course iations tout le temps
j'ai parlé avec où les 22 acteurs de
police pour les vies des corps de deux
soeurs personne mais écoute on est une
institution de formation puis on est là
pour aider notre clientèle on est là
pour intégrer ces nouveaux où l'on joué
et perdu monsieur green monsieur grecque
vous êtes là imposable ou quelques
petits soucis oui la conversation a
coupé une fat plus écoutée on va on va
s'arrêter là mais bon je pense que la
table est mise on sait les besoins qui
sont là pour que les changements
puissent s'amorcer dans la société
merci à tous les trois alors je vais
vous représentez monsieur eileen gray
vous êtes donc un instructeur
coordinateur à l'école nationale de
police de nicolet
vous êtes un ig mag de listuguj en
gaspésie merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
aujourd'hui avec nous également oui dia
la rivière où doit être unanime nabu
vous êtes de témiscaming c'est bien ça
au mondial exactement et vous est la
cofondatrice de cet organisme dans
conscientisation d'éducation mick hannah
et puis isabelle de picard une web
d'arte de wade à qui vous avez qui est
la première spécialistes aux affaires
autochtones à radio-canada merci
beaucoup merci à toutes les trois
d'avoir accepté de participer à cette
discussion qui reste ouverte et encore
beaucoup de choses à dire et j'en
profite à tous les trois pour vous
souhaiter un bon mois nationale des
autochtones et à très bientôt
merci
[Musique]
m